we have a lot of things we only have
four bills today but it's probably gonna
be the longest time it's taken us to
deal with four bills
i'm going to call
on
senate bill 209 and 276
and then we're going to have another
caucus with our group um
i want everyone to have their
opportunity
to review all the different amendments
that are going to be in front of each
of us
last week as you recall
trying to be a nice guy
and getting in trouble for it
uh house bill 209
so we have to go through
um
nice guy i'm sorry the 276 is the first
one i'm going to bring up we do have to
call the role first mr clerk and we do
have two
uh replacements representative almighty
thank you for joining us
infantine here
seaworth here
avalani
pelham
mackie myself present love yep
warden good morning
yeah proud here boyd here
murder for huff
sullivan yep susie here
rudy
cahill here lisa vestro here schmidt
here
toomey yeah bouchard here edgerton yeah
only for mandeville
and
one more
no there's one more i said you last
night i'm sorry
representative huff
is out
yeah oh i got that mark what murder okay
i didn't hear your calls oh yeah i did
susan and tony troy your first time in
the labor committee no no
it's not i was i was on this committee a
couple of terms ago okay when i was
going
when i tried to retire
so brian did i send you the email with
the uh motions we have to do basically
folks what we have to do
is we have to
reconsider the vote
i will tell you what what went down
we thought we were doing the right thing
we had members of the
uh sponsors of the bill in support of it
we had a member of uh house ways and
means and house finance in favor of what
we were trying to do
the amendment is non-germane
we knew that
in my naivete i thought i had the
ability with everyone's agreement to
make that decision whether or not a
germain
non-jermaine amendment could be
brought forth
it is not the case
it needs the speaker as well as the
chairman to agree and then it has to go
to a hearing a non-jermaine hearing
so we did everything wrong
so that being said
i'm going to open the executive session
on house bill 276 and i'm going to
recognize
representative seaworth for an amendment
um
thank you mr chairman having voted on
the prevailing side on the octopass is
amended for 276 i'd like to move
reconsideration
second motion has been made seconded by
representative sullivan
he may speak to you motion i think the
uh
explanation both in email and from the
chairman is pretty clear
uh we we tried to help out and it didn't
work
and so the approach we're going to have
to take is undo
the amendment that we shouldn't have
done in the first place and then we can
uh
vote again on the original bill
but i wouldn't like to speak
on this motion in front of us
sitting down the motion on the floor is
reconsideration of the ought to pass
on senate bill 276.
would you please call the roll seaworth
yes
avalani
callum yes esophagus love yes warden yes
haircut yes proud yes
boyd yes
burner
yes
sullivan
yes susie yes rudy
cahill
yes diesel estro
schmidt
yes toomey yes bouchard yes headset yeah
army yes
unanimous
yes
oh i'm sorry infotainment
no it's unanimous twenty zero
the um
motion pass is open for further
amendment or motions
uh i would like to make a motion to
reconsider the
adoption of the amendment
moved and seconded by representative
sullivan
and we'd like to speak
on the motion
say none mr clerk when you have a moment
he's writing down all the stuff here so
we'll give him a second
seaworth
yes
avalani
callum yes myself yes love
yes
warden yes turcotte yes pro yes boyd yes
murder yes sullivan yes susie yes bruti
cahill yes diesel vestro
schmidt yes toomey yes bouchard yes
edgerton yes
army yes
inventory yes
the motion has passed yes
it is open for
further
well
and at this point we need to we we're
reconsidering that the vote that we took
and that i voted for to adopt the
amendment and so now we need to take
that vote again
and this time
i will be voting no and would urge
everyone to do the same so voting on the
amendment
and you're recommending itl on the
yes
everyone
so first we had to reconsider the ought
to pass as amended
second we have to reconsider
the amendment
so we're now
reconsidered both of them so we're back
to where we were
we now have the amendment
which was brought forth
and we will vote that down
uh and then we can uh vote to adopt the
initial bill if you'd like so
representative alma has a question on
just that we aren't trying to itl the
amendment we're just not accepting the
amendment
okay
okay so what is the motion
if it's not
if it's
motion
right
and we don't
know what we do make it interesting
i'm just having a brain cramp here let
me figure out so the amendments on the
table were voting against the amendment
you're just doing it the way you
normally would yeah okay sorry are you
correct it's not an ito
um do you know the amendment number by
chance i do i'll find it for you here
because everyone brought their packages
right
you know i may have tossed it
let me keep looking here
it may have even
know if we had the paper copies on our
team we did it
what is the amendment number
representative bouchard
1835h
1489 s is in sam
yes i thought
because a senator it drafted the version
that was that was in front of us so it
wasn't
that was another reason it was not
correct
just a moment representative
1489 yes
representative avalon you recognize
yes
the motion on the floor is
adopt the amendment
well we already adopted it
so what we have done now is we
reconsidered
and since it was already adopted
i think we have to
since we reconsidered the adoption we
now have to say yes or no
we have to reconsider both there's a
pass with amendments
that's okay it's good to have the
conversation about the procedure so we
passed a bill with an amendment so we
have to both reconsider the bill
as passed with the amendment and the
amendment
so we reconsider them so now back in
front of us
is the bill as amended
or so now we have to
unamend it
yeah
can mr chairman can the chairman just
rule that that amendment is non-germane
and since we haven't had a public
hearing that it can't be considered
the only reason i'm doing as i act have
i asked for specific instructions from
the house clerk okay so i would rather
we follow the explicit construction
follow
the clerk okay
i already have two strikes against me so
and from that standpoint we're in the
voting mode we're in the process of
voting in this amendment and have been
for
quite some time now and so we have to
finish what we're doing we can't just
stop and say ah let's forget this and do
something else mr chairman
yes representative move the question on
the amendment
so
the the third go ahead representative
the motion of the floor is
to adopt
the amendment the number that we just
14.89
so the to adopt the 1489 s and hopefully
you will be voting no okay
any other questions
uh mr clerk please uh seaworth no
avaloni no
calum no myself no love no
warden no
turcotte no wrote no
boyd no burner no
sullivan nope susie no rudy
cahill
uh
no
i know
it's open for further uh further motion
uh
vice chairman seaworth
i move ought to pass on the original
language most of the floors ought to
pass and i'm going to go with the if i
could continue uh
representative um
seconded by representative sullivan
um
you're recognized to speak to your
motion representative thank you mr
chairman the underlying bill was very
simple
uh we could wonder also why we got that
version of the bill
because all it does is changes the
reporting requirements to make it clear
that the reports have to be delivered on
time and that they have to go to ways
and means in both the house and the
senate
so
um in our discussion nobody had any
issue with this portion of the bill
i
uh will therefore be voting yes to pass
the original version
thank you representative sullivan
seeing how representative almi is here
to supervise this process i would
recommend that we all vote yes
yes i questioned as well why that bill
this bill came to us but oh well
that's uh
we have more committees and i guess they
do so i don't know so anyone else like
to speak on behalf
of the ought to pass on house senate
bill 276
representative army i just want to thank
you all for passing it
yes and
i do too actually you know
being a manchester guy and what's going
on with this piece of legislation and
what they're trying to do down there
which will probably be good for all of
us in the future
mr clark would you please call the roll
seaworth yes
avalani yes carolyn yes myself yes love
yes warden yes turcotte yes bro yes boyd
yes merner yes sullivan yes susie yes
brody
cahill yes lisa vestro
schmidt yes toomey
bouchard yes adjutant yes omi yes
infantine yes 20-0
any objections at consent agenda
say none thank you very much
next bill i'd like to take up is senate
bill 377 fn and i call
on representative avalani
calling for your motion on senate bill
377 fn
thank you mr chairman i move interim
study
second
motions made by representative olani
seconded by representative turcotte
representative babalani you're
recognized to speak to your motion thank
you mr chairman um there were some
questions as to whether we should be
expanding some of this to include uh
given the testimony that it was to or
from security details or to and from
off-duty details
to cover the time traveled between their
home and going home
also to include fish and game maybe the
sheriff's
office also has vehicles that are taken
home by their employees that are also
used for details or outside
off-duty
special details and security um also if
there's a local officer that leaves
their jurisdiction would they be covered
as well
um those were the questions i had and
none of them were
seem to have any answers so that's the
reason for the interim study so we can
get answers and maybe expand this
to include
other
levels of police officers
sullivan followed by representative
cahill
i frankly don't disagree with any of
that
um
however i
think we have an opportunity here to
solve a problem for the state police
and um
and then if it needs to be expanded i
mean if we get answers to all those
questions um which we should
um and we find that we need to expand it
we can expand it with a new bill
um but if we pass this bill we can solve
a problem for the state police it seemed
like a legitimate problem seemed like
you know we would leave them still
vulnerable to not getting the workers
comp that they ought to
and if we pass it now we can solve one
problem if there are other problems to
be solved
next year's another year we can do that
um with a new bill
so
i would uh vote against the uh
the interim study and would prefer not
to pass so that we can as i said solve
one problem and then later perhaps solve
others thank you
representative cahill followed by um
warden
uh thank you mr chair and basically what
what he said but i you know we've this
problem has been identified and there
while there may be others and i agree
with mr avilani that we should look at
that but next year we could we could do
that we'll have the time and i think we
i would vote out to pass on
this year
thank you
yeah thank you
in reading the plain language of the
bill
reads me by the way it says there shall
be a premium prima facie presumption
that any injury sustained by a troop
raider by a trooper operating a vehicle
and to my
understanding and interpretation of that
plain language that only refers to the
trooper while operating the state police
vehicle
yet we heard a bunch of testimony in the
public hearing about
stopping for a detail or stopping for an
accident details slip and fall outside
the vehicle but this
clear definition here would only apply
to somebody behind the wheel
driving or operating that vehicle and
from the test point that wasn't the
intent so that's why i agree with the
idea of our interim study to really
drill down on this make sure we're all
on the same page of what the original
intent was and see if we can address
that thank you
again
i am angry that i have to be the tying
oh
it's poor legislation
and poor
uh management of government on the this
on the legislative side
when one guy has to make the decision
between
one party on one side and one party in
the other
it's really frustrating
i called senator carson twice
didn't receive a call back
i wanted to know what the impetus was
behind this
was there a claim denied is there a
problem
i am a big supporter as you all know
of the law enforcement
and
i was
surprised by
my fellow republicans with the concerns
and then
the expeditious part of me said let's
just pass it and we'll fix it
well
what are we trying to solve
is it as soon as they get called because
they're closer to the closest
officer to the scene
or they happen to see something
you know see some
reckless drivers going whatever doing
crazy stuff and they have to respond
it it's
the current law allows for certain
things i mean
in current workers compensation law
if i have a job or i have to stop and
see four
clients during the day the minute i
leave my house i'm covered
to go see all those people no matter
what happens to me whether i slept in
the parking lot or i get in a car
accident
yet if i go to my office first i'm not
um
there's all kinds of different
machinations and i don't think we've
covered them here what are they what are
they trying to solve
i don't know
and it bothers
really bothers me
that we have to send this interim study
but
what are we passing and what are we
solving what was the problem that
started it
and what are we trying
to
define and get covered i don't think
there's any question
that the people that are going to vote
for interim study
would like this bill to pass
it's just ridiculously frustrating
um
i have told the lobbyist
for the
um supporting this with the troopers
association
go find a house bill
and fix this
maybe we can be in committee uh
um
we need a conference and figure it out
i'm just beyond frustrated
anybody else like to speak on this
say none please call the roll the motion
on the floor is interim study
yes sullivan no
susie no
rudy no cahill no lisa
yeah
schmidt
no
to me
the um
clerk i saw a couple of you asking
the
clark mis stated
the first number of bills when he said
20 to nothing
it was 21.
anyone who were
all right it is 10 30 we're going to
take a 15 minute caucus
and the bills when we come back will be
209 and
3 45 and there are amendments so make
sure everyone has copies if you are
submitting an amendment please make sure
there are copies
um if you've got them with heather that
they're out for everyone to receive and
you've looked at them
um and brian represents he worth the
other question oh i know he's going to
ask uh
the minority report as an author yet
no i'm sure they didn't expect it to to
be coming so
you will have one though right
okay
all right we'll see you in 15 minutes
everyone
as long as you sign the checks correctly
it doesn't matter
suppose it's correct on the
yeah
well you're only supposed to have two
eyes anyway
yeah
they're caucusing on what you'll know
oh that's the one on me
i thought they already had a car
consistently
well there must be borders coming down
oh i guess
i don't know well that was so confusing
last week you laughed you had to get an
appointment right maybe half hour after
that and someone said well let's let's
how about let's go for this
we were hearing testimony when i left
right and then as we finished up will
said i think that we can if nobody minds
well exactly today and he said yeah
sure we did but obviously
the whole thing was
not correct
does anybody know what happened did
anybody hear any
reason
that's a really hard thing to find out
sometimes
because nobody wants to commit
who made the error
i could figure out
section that talks about shouldn't
employ your employee
access
to detect the process
either replacement payroll parent check
direct deposit
um
the ironic part of it is that the one
semi-decent consumer production phase of
the bill
was not
reactionary
so since i didn't
so basically the uh
he's taken out the uh
section
it deals with uh student employee
unable to access the wages
yes
it has to already be legal
my
five
i have a number of amendments
uh first of all i have to um
well let me think about this
i'll call representative seaworth for a
motion
so we start with autopass
and then it'll be open for a minute
sorry do i move on to pass
no we can't do that no we don't yeah i
think we have start with our comments no
starting amendment
okay
sorry guys
been a crazy couple days
opening this executive session on senate
bill 345 and um call on representative
adigen for a motion
thank you mr chairman i'd like to move
amendment
2022-15-35-h
and i'd like to speak to the amendment
all right the motion has been um
made
amendment uh number two zero two two one
five three five eights
uh seconded by representative sullivan
you're um you recognize speak your
motion thank mr chairman um
at every point
uh that this bill has been discussed in
a hearing whether it was senate commerce
or here
a week or two weeks ago um the concept
of
a labor shortage has been
one way or another used as a
justification uh for the expansion of
ours um i'm very concerned that instead
of
doing things like raising the minimum
wage uh having better workplace
protections um
doing anything to make the currently
unfilled jobs
actually more attractive to potential
applicants uh
the theory behind it seems to be in some
part well we'll just have the kids do
that um i don't like that i i've
expressed
my
concern that students being
out working that late
uh at 9 or 10 p.m
or 10 p.m is in the original language uh
would
make it so that they have a difficult
time doing their homework especially if
they have a longer commute time
i know i grew up in bridgewater new
hampshire and i worked at the tilton
market basket um that was a 35 minute
drive easily um under the new
legislation i'd be getting home at about
10 30 10 40 10 45
and i think that's just too late so um
i think setting an 8 pm time is good um
that's what i have to say about that
thank you very much
i really like to speak
on the motion
i'm sorry john i represented matt i
apologize i get looking over here
um
i represent an area that has a lot of
seasonal businesses
and
this apparently is a year-round
restriction the way it's written
and
frankly that is impossible there's too
many
children who are youth who are perfectly
willing to work those hours the parents
are perfectly willing to have them work
those hours
and there's no reason we should be
restricting their ability to work those
hours
okay
so you know no one else wanted to speak
the motion on the floor is
i'm sorry i couldn't see it
well
you moved over there calvin's right in
the middle i can't see you
uh
thank you mr chairman um
the
section b
um we heard testimony from the gentleman
um
from aroma joe's that
they're you know
some of their employees only like to
work three or four days three or four
hours a day should they be only
allowed to work you know if say they
want to work six days
at four hours a day only want to work 24
hours a week should they be limited to
the number of days that they can
actually work
outside of the school year
thank you mr chairman i would simply say
to that that we as adults have an
understanding um that a work week
um
in standard practice has uh two days off
a rest period um i don't see why that
should be different for children
okay seeing no other questions the
motion on the floor has been made and
seconded
to the attitude
amendment 2022-1535h
mr clerk please call the role
seaworth
no
avilani
callum
no
myself no
love nope
warden no
jerk cut no
wrote no boyd no
murder no
sullivan no
susie
no
rudy no cahill
steve sylvestro
schmidt no toomey
bouchard no adjutant yes
army
no
invention
the bill is open for further um
amendment i call on um representative
cahill
move motion 202216058
representative
kale you can
thank you mr chairman um
i have a different spin on this
i'm sorry i i kind of overstated what i
should have said here i call on you for
introduce your amendment so please
introduce your amendment oh yes
uh i'd like to introduce amendment uh
two two zero two zero two two one six o
five h and uh seconded by
representative uh bouchard
thank you okay motion of the floor is
made in the second of your speak to you
you're
recognized to speak to your motion or
it's your amendment thank you mr
chairman
uh
in in this amendment we we limit the
work for 16 and 17 year olds to
uh during the months in which school is
in session
now that may vary it may be that one one
place starts
after labor day another does the last
week of august but in either case
there's they're not in sessions so
if they're not in session they are free
to work unlimited hours but during the
time that the school is in session
then 16 to 17 year olds will not work
more than 35 hours
in
the week other than the school's
vacation week so we know that those vary
as well
but i think the employer
and the department would know when the
school is in session that in that
district that area and when their
vacation week occurs so outside of
outside when they're not in school
either through the school's vacation or
through the summer months
there's no limit on on their working
within those times 35 hours
and then we go on to talk about night
work so the uh they will be during the
school when school is in session they
could not work later than nine o'clock
which i think is better than 10 o'clock
which was in the original bill
uh sunday through thursday and could
work until 12 a.m on friday and saturday
nights
so
we're giving them the 35 hours that was
requested and we're just dialing back
uh
from 10 to nine
and
making quite a bit simpler just asking
that they
limiting the the
hours
during the school when school is in
session which is the time we're trying
to make sure they're doing their
homework studying for the test preparing
for the rest of their working careers
thank you mr chair
thank you
seaworth
thank you mr chairman i'll um
stick to section two since i'll talk to
section three next
um my concern here well i'll back up so
this bill
came to us from the senate
in an effort to
redu take areas of the law where there's
confusion
and burdens on the employers trying to
comply with how things are written
and and simplify that
to me section 2
in practice would be
pretty similar to what the the
underlying bill
suggests
but to me it's also more complicated it
has people trying to figure out these
things about whether it's a month when
school's in session when it's a week
that it's a school vacation week
i think
to
cut to the chase i think this adds
complexity to the regulation rather than
reduces it
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and i always look
forward to representative cahill's bills
um
and amendments
i have a question what if the student is
out of state goes to maine massachusetts
or vermont for schooling would we have
to follow their school year or we would
have to follow our school year
well
when i see that penn
i know there's a good question coming
from mr avilani and i don't know the
answer and i don't know what happens
under current law
we're gonna have attitude you say is
there a giant difference between the
school years on one side of the
connecticut river and the other
i i'm not
vacation weeks
but surprise
rivers of babylonia and then
representative alame uh thank you again
mr chairman
um if it's in a week other than a
school's vacation week we had discussion
during the hearing
of kids that are on work study
would they be able to partake in that
because it specifically says they
wouldn't be able to work one 35
35 hours only during a school vacation
week
thank you for the question i i'm not
quite sure how the department looks at
work study if they are familiar with the
issue i'm sure they have a way to
evaluate that and not penalize the
employer
or the young person who wants to work
but i i'm unclear about that
you're welcome
i also do appreciate
i say this with sincerity uh
representative cahill's uh
amendments and intent and he and i with
a number of emails going back and forth
and while i agree with where he's trying
to go with this i i expressed that i am
concerned that it's not so much the
department of labor
it's the employers themselves we heard
from a couple employers that there's a
lot of confusion in the law and the
whole goal is to make this more simple
and i do believe that that word month
it could be problematic um you know the
kid gets out two weeks
the second week of june and well that's
a school month well is that a vacation
week
because it's school vacation is summer
actually school vacation summer i don't
know or is that just like no school
sessions so
i i i do appreciate it i'm i'm i can't
support it but i do appreciate what
you've done because i just think we're
trying to make it more
succinct and this may have just opened
it to be more confusing
representative sullivan
while this might come up slightly short
of being perfectly clear
i would suggest that it is far more
clear than the current statute
which
i agree we heard lots of testimony maybe
not lots we've heard testimony that
employers are confused by the current
statute
and i believe this
amendment is far clearer than the
current statute is
and i would support it
representative did i say i was going to
recognize you and i didn't recognize you
i apologize sorry i just want to point
out that the west
has a different school vacation week
than the east of the state
thank you
representative love
thank you for taking my question uh my
my question would be is how how would
this apply to homeschoolers uh they you
know they have different schooling hours
different vacations different everything
and there's nothing in this that
that applies to them
thank you for the question i've
discussed that issue with deputy
ogden and he says that currently and i
imagine this would continue they look at
the
district and where the student lives
so if you're in home school or you're in
your town it would be the same
uh presumption of school time
and if i may
and i believe this would encourage
people to
hollow the uh
hire the youth knowing that it's not
it's either summertime or it isn't
and it's a school vacation it's you know
it's twice a year that happens it's not
that difficult to follow and i did work
rather closely with mr ogden getting
this legislation prepared
so
i would i would ask you to support it
seeing no one else willing to speak
mr clark would you please call
the role on
amendment 2022-1605
seaworth no seaworth
no
avalani
callum no
myself no love no warden no turcot no
bro no boyd no
murder no
sullivan yes susie yes rudy yeah cahill
yes
lisa vestro
schmidt yes toomey yes bouchard yes
henson yes army yes
infantine no
bill's open for further amendment
representative seaworth thank you mr
chairman i would like to offer amendment
2022-1607
h
second
motion has been made by governor
seaworth second by representative
turcotte
you're recognized to speak to your
motion thank you and as i hinted now i
get to talk about the third section of
the bill which is night work
it was it was a number of terms ago we
had a bill with a lot of pieces that
came to this committee to deal with
youth employment
and during the testimony people kept
asking well is this bill gonna deal with
night work is this gonna fix night work
what are you gonna do about night work
and i thought to myself what what is
this night work
and sometimes i regret that i ever asked
that question because over the years i
came to learn a lot about night work
um
i offer this amendment which is is very
short it repeals two sections of the law
the first one is the night work section
that's in a13 and then a14 it also
repeals
the ability of the commissioner to give
exceptions
to 213 so the two have to come together
and in doing this i think i've taken the
one common denominator to every
amendment that's um
that's come into this bill every single
amendment repeals the existing law
the existing night work law and this was
how it was written from the beginning
it's how it's held up through the
amendments
is basically a restriction on overtime
it's kind of a complicated restriction
on overtime and then it has to do with
hours of work and number of days work
and and once you hit the right
combination
then your shifts are limited to eight
hours a day but that's what it hits it's
not really
defining conditions for working at night
as
the title might imply and the result of
this is that
employers either don't understand how it
applies and are afraid of it so they try
to stay away from the whole area or they
do understand
but it's too complicated for them to
keep track of all these moving pieces
and so they don't hire teens because of
fear of this law from the department of
labor we've heard that the problems are
again
misunderstandings people thinking that
there are laws that don't exist and
saying but isn't there this night work
and doesn't that do something and they
have to explain no so again the common
denominator was repealing this existing
law
is supported across the board
in the underlying bill the senate has
put forth
something else not a limitation on
overtime as the law that's repealed is
but a new restriction kind of a curfew
on when
what hours
16 and 17 year olds can work and when
they can't
we heard during testimony we've talked
about in in as these amendments come
forward
it seems kind of that they didn't fully
think through the implication of what
they wrote
and i would argue this is
the problem is in the process that in
repealing to also then in add in a new
area of law that impacts
employers
students families in ways that we just
haven't thought through
that's a result from rushing it and i
don't think the right way to fix that
a senate rush job is for then us in the
house to try to throw something together
um over a holiday weekend
so
i would ask you to support this simple
repeal
it's something we all agree on
um if a new bill is is desired that
wants to put more restrictions on teen
workers and employers
maybe that should be its own bill
um
as i said i've spent a lot of years in
night work i i worked on the language
that's in there
i kind of felt that the night work would
be my legacy
that my contribution to the future of
the state of new hampshire
would be night work
and so
i am willing to let go of night work and
i asked my friends on the committee to
do the same
thank you thank you representative
followed by sullivan
thank you mr chairman uh representative
seaworth if you'd mind answering uh just
to be clear under this language um
repealing the night work section it
would in fact be possible for a 16 year
old to work until 5am the following day
correct
that is correct and even if we don't
repeal it it would be possible for a
teenager to work until 5 00 pm the
following day
5 am five five a.m
no further
representative sullivan
um one thing i will say for this it is
simple
maybe a little too simple um
right now as i understand it from the
testimony we heard
most employers because the current
statute is quite confusing and hard to
manage they simply don't have kids work
past eight um so if effectively um the
current language could read
no um
16 or 17 year olds shall work past 8 pm
on any day
that's the way it's being interpreted um
and or applied not interpreted um
so um
the senate opened it up and said
let's put some limit on it
they tried to do it
10 p.m
on school nights i think they missed
and
12 a.m on
saturday or friday and saturday
then i think the senator acknowledged
senator hennessey acknowledged that
her
language needed some work
i think having no limitations on night
work
for
16 and 17 year olds is a step too far
so i would suggest that some type of
limitation is appropriate um i could
live with i think eight o'clock is too
early um
i could live with nine o'clock i could
live a ten ten o'clock on a school night
i think 12 a.m on a friday and saturday
um is also just fine
um but um
i think no limitation is a step too far
so
i would not support
this very simple
amendment
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman in researching um
to refresh myself seeing as this is my
first term in the labor committee and
i've had to learn a lot this year
um
i looked into what the federal um
labor laws are pertaining to 14 and 15
year olds the current maximum cap is 18
hours a week
and it's no earlier and no later than 7
pm
under the proposed amendment
you would be going from a 15 year old
who is not allowed to work past
pm
to
the day after they turn 16
devoid of any further context or changes
in their school workload
uh or anything else you have a student
that starts their junior year where
they're starting to take ap classes at
all of a sudden they turn 16 and now
there is absolutely no restriction to
the amount of time that an employer can
schedule them i'm not even going to say
that the kid can work it's the employer
can schedule them because we were all
here when deputy commissioner ogden sat
up there
and said oftentimes the department of
labor fields
calls from parents who say
well my kid got scheduled to work until
11 pm i don't want them working until 11
pm but i understand that if i complain
to the manager then my student will get
replaced by as he put it somebody else
who can
um
i i recognize the amendment that i put
forward earlier um was a bit too much
for folks that's fine um but i also
think this is too far in the other
direction
um so i would be opposing this amendment
thank you
anyone else like to speak
i'm sorry mike i did call i did
recognize my merchant of cahill followed
by avilani thank you mr chair uh i will
oppose this amendment i i think it is uh
way too far
we i we do have a responsibility to our
our children
and and and the employers to be fine to
balance and i think that during the
school year
we shouldn't have people working late i
spoke to a parent this morning a parent
of twin boys
and he said he'd like them in bed at 10
o'clock
he doesn't really want i mean whether we
know the kids may not be at 10 o'clock
they may be reading or doing
video games but they're home and they're
not at an employer which pulls them some
distance away working
until you know who knows what hour i
guess it could be 5 p and the next day
under this under this amendment
you could just work unlimited hours
so i i think this is too far and i think
as far you know it's very simple but the
complexity we have now
was put there by the author of this
simple amendment
and we can't just undo all of that i
think we could simplify with uh maybe we
have an amendment or two left
or we could reconsider
uh a previous uh vote and and make it
simple for everyone concerned but this
is not something i can support
thank you mr chairman um
removing the restrictions on night work
for youth
um would be for 16 and 17 year olds
um to representative adjudance points if
a youth can't work past eight o'clock i
mean heard testimony from the gentleman
from aroma joe's they just schedule
somebody else anyways so if that youth
worked on nine o'clock he might be
scheduled to close that day instead of
losing that shift to something that's
older and doesn't has the ability to
stay longer
again to 12 a.m on friday saturday night
what if there is a culinary student or
electrical student that wants to do a
special project they're unable to do
that
if it's an overnight job i mean
where do we
tell you if they can work and then can't
work and are we removing people from the
workforce based on arbitrary numbers
for night work um that's
my two cents thank you
thank you
all right you're gonna have to listen to
my three-minute diatribe here guys
my mother grew up in caribou maine
and they used to take two weeks off
after school started to pick potatoes
because her dad was a farmer and that's
how you
made your money to have money for the
school year and new clothes and so i
grew up hearing stories about my mom
picking potatoes my dad reading meters
up in up in canton new york in the
freezing cold having to read electric
meters and
hopefully someone would let him in and
give him a hot cup of coffee or cocoa or
something when he's doing that so
obviously things have changed you know
when the first 7-eleven opened that's
because they were open from 7 a.m to 11
p.m some of the people or themselves and
you and i remember as kids when things
were shut down at five o'clock that's it
mom had to go shopping during the week
because at five or six o'clock the
stores close down
so obviously now we have a 24 hour
not just united states but global
economy
where
kids are put into all different
aspects and every single one of you
makes a great point
something where someone has to drive 30
miles away or more in the north country
versus someone sitting in the lakes
region where their
july 4th weekend they can you know work
as late as they can because they just
need more and more employees
so
it's a very complicated situation and we
try to
make
this
work for everybody
and i remember getting into an argument
a couple years ago what is was someone
with a goal here in the labor committee
and they said well it's to take care of
employees and someone said no it's not
to take care of employers no it's not
let's take care of everybody as best we
can as even as we can as fairly as we
can but everyone's different everyone
has a different situation
we have kids that come to the boys and
girls club every morning
you know um in manchester because they
haven't eaten
and maybe we don't understand that but
there's certain people that have to work
and there's certain people that it's
more of a luxury to have to work
when they're in high school so we're
trying to take all these different
things that exist here and put them all
into one thing it's very difficult and i
appreciate everyone's willingness to try
to do that
but even some of the things we've talked
about today
are not necessarily going to work
transportation
committee in the legislature passed a
bill a few years ago that said if you're
under 18 you can't drive past 11 o'clock
at night
so is this going to preclude certain
people
from working till 11 o'clock at night
their parents have to come pick them up
because technically they're not supposed
to drive
i talked to the department of labor he
said what happens if a kid goes to work
at 3am
because he's got to be at the farm for
the farmer at 3 a.m so he can help milk
the cows and do everything so he can get
to school by 8.
no restrictions on that so we're we're
trying to worry about a kid going to bed
at night
and what time they're going to go to bed
during a school night or a week night
or weekend night it was at eight nine
ten o'clock a good night but it's okay
if they get up at three o'clock in the
morning to go work at the farm
so
honestly this entire concept should have
gone to some big study committee and
dealt with appropriately
but we're here with what we are here now
so thank you for listening to my
diatribe
um
but
it's how i try to make my thought
process trying to take in all the
different things in my in my
life
try to make the best decision possible
trying to remember what it was like when
all of us remember when all of you were
16 and 17.
you worked who worked in the grocery
store
i worked in the grand union
okay and so i i
you know i tried to take all those
things into play and quite frankly
nothing we have here is perfect and
i question um this night work
whether it's going to be applicable
because again at 11 o'clock brian you
can't be driving in the road the state
police this police can stop you because
of a youthful driver you can't drive
after 11 o'clock
so who knows how that's going to affect
this
don't know
we'll have to figure it out and
hopefully
if we pass something here and it goes to
the senate we can have a committee
conference and
and and i can uh make make uh
representative attitude cahill and
avilani work work hard on that and
figure out a solution that's going to
make everybody happy but in the interim
so that is my that is my point here this
nothing's perfect um
but i'm trying to take into effect that
people that do need to work
because they need it
because they don't have the
the their parents don't have the
discretionary income for the things they
need
versus those that you know
um
it's more of a a nicety
so i
apologize but that's my uh my comments
and well i will support this albeit not
perfect
uh rubs of agent
thank you mr chairman i did hear you say
during uh your commentary um that you
wished this had gone to a big study
committee um i would like to point out
for the committee that it is entirely
possible um that the otp motion could be
defeated and that this could be sent to
interim study which is something that we
did earlier
so i agree that this
should be looked into more because there
are
a considerable number of
uh things to be discussed
i suggested in the last couple days
punting this to a work session um but
we're really pressed up against
deadlines so
it didn't seem like that was going to
happen
um i i would just put that out there
that uh we are not tied to the current
motion that is on the floor
turcotte thank you mr chairman
i will rise in support of this uh
amendment um
i believe the bureaucracy that governs
best governs least and i also have a lot
of faith in uh
parents the underage youth employee
employee
the employee and the employer
relationship
and i think
as
this with many other bills
the the less we get involved
implementing what we as individuals or
as group think believe should happen
that it's best left to the individuals
that are involved in the situation to
make that decision so i fully support
this
this amendment
is that representative bouchard
thank you
for taking my
testimony here and i just wanted to uh
add to representative turcotte's idea of
letting
parents and
industry decide
uh
what's best i come from a city
uh manchester that
had that type of
philosophy with the amiscake mills so
that is the reason why i think
possibly what we need to do is to go
through
interim study thank you
thank you
see no more comments
references to george orwell 1984 would
group think i will ask the clerk to call
the role i was out of brutality
yeah thank you mr chairman um
we all believe that
we all love our children and want to
take care of them
but there are people out there who don't
care that much about their children
and don't care how much they work
during our caucus i mentioned a family
where
three underprivileged kids would work
their father would take them to work
pick them up and collect their paycheck
and that guy didn't work at all
so
we all don't i mean i think we're all
decent people here but the real world is
not everybody cares for their kids like
we would
thank you
point point very well tyken thank you
seeing no other
uh comments
clerk would you please call the roll on
amendment 2022-16078
seaworth yes
avalani
callum
yes
myself yes love yes warden yes
turcotte yes
wrote yes
uh boyd yes
right now my sheets are modified uh
murder
yes
sullivan no
susie
nope
beruti no
cahill no lisa vestro
schmidt
no
to me no
bouchard now
adjutant no
almi no
infantine yes
11 10.
bill's open for further amendment
call representative schmidt
thank you mr chairman
uh
i propose amendment uh 2022-1623-h
um basically the only change hopefully
motion's been made seconded by
representatives sorry
sullivan
motion's been made and seconded your
representative you're recognized to
speak anymore thank you um
the last two lines on this amendment are
really what
i think answers the middle ground
between managing too closely and being
confusing and throwing the whole law out
with a bathwater
i think we have to be very careful
to
set limits for our children i think we
have to set limits to protect businesses
and our children
i think we have to worry about where
they are what they're doing
and this is very clear if you have
school the following day you may not
work past nine o'clock
period
on friday and saturday you're free to
work until
12.
you can work 35 hours a week and that
can be accomplished with this schedule
i think working till nine as a
youth
is an appropriate time even if you have
to drive home you're not going to work
an hour from home
it would be very reasonable hours
and
it simplified this we received a letter
recently from an employer who said this
is so confusing i can't follow it this
is
convoluted and we know it is this law
labor law has been in there and changed
year after year after year and for all
the years i've been here we have found
more crazy things in law that need to be
changed
we we thought perhaps there would be a
subcommittee working on all of labor law
then on a portion of it
it would be a good idea to overhaul it
with the help of the labor department
but i think until now this clarifies
for employers what they can schedule
and helps protect our kids from working
too many hours
that's all i really wanted to say
thank you
representative proud
thank you mr chairman um
some only questions i have reading the
news section we're talking about for
night work in this amendment is it
doesn't seem clear what the restriction
is or if there's any at all on
for a sunday night when monday's a
holiday it looks like that night would
be unrestricted
and the
youth employee could work as late as
they wanted i think this is this is
entirely clear if you have school the
following day then you can't work past
nine that would take care of monday
holidays it would even for wednesday
when the teachers are off and school is
closed if you school not
yes when the available day was a holiday
so they could work to past midnight till
1am 3 am
anytime at all
in when there's a monday holiday on any
school day
that follows you can't work past nine
thank you
i'm pausing because i'm thinking because
i think i i see the disconnect here
between what you were trying to
perhaps the last line instead of the
last three words instead of on friday or
saturday it should say other days
i think would make it a lot more clear
to address the issue i'm trying to get
at
thank you
yeah
anyone else represent sullivan and then
followed by cahill
i i agree that there is a little glitch
there um i would however say this is uh
probably um it's not as simple as um
representative seaworth's um but it does
provide some sort of guidance as to
how late a
student can
can work
and i think having
no limitation on any day
is as i said a step too far this does uh
provide some guidance um
it um
i i don't know if there's a way that we
could agree to amend the amendment
um and and then continue to vote with
without it having a official number
but um or we could
but
i think the the improvement that uh
representative
schmidt
suggested would would be great
but
i would say this is probably the
clearest one we've got so far that
provides some guidance i will support it
representative
thank you mr chairman i i think that
this would be the preferred amendment uh
for this bill if in fact we could either
uh
suspend and and worked on the other bill
while the
amendment was
uh pursued with lls maybe we could get
it done today or we could have a floor
amendment
to correct that small piece at the end
so that we would have the protections
for our youth and the clarity that is
currently missing in current law
thank you mr chairman just a question on
um
line four and five um i understand the
designated work week but could you
define what julie enrolled in school
means
what that means
i'm not
i'm not sure why you think it's unclear
um if someone has left school at 17
because they no longer want to be in
school then they wouldn't fall under
this law at all
clarification
thank you um so a homeschooler is not
duly enrolled in school
or a charter school is not julie
enrolled in school charter is so it's
school year for the district school year
or is it
something other than that
well charter schools are duly enrolled
students i'm not exactly sure how home
school students
would fit into this
isn't the dually enrolled in school
current law yes it is
currently looking at it yeah okay
but it doesn't give definitions
well then you look at rules all right so
are you uh
finished with your inquiry or your
question representative about it or
would you like to follow up or or
you're all set
um
did anyone else
thank you mr chairman um
an issue i hadn't really considered much
until rep beloved brought it up on a on
one of the other previous bills is the
home schools
so
looking at lines 15 and 16 on here
we were told that the homeschoolers this
would apply to the district with chin
within within that that student is
located is the way i understood it
so let's just say the home and i'm not
sure how the
homeschoolers
necessarily structure their their
schedules or their week but let's just
say that the homeschooler
their school week consisted of
friday saturday sunday and monday work
where they were off during the middle of
the week
this would preclude those homeschoolers
then from working at night because their
regulations are based upon
night work contained in this rsa
is that correct
i believe that homeschoolers
their schedule is the same as the
location that they are they are in
that's what this law would assume
i don't believe that's correct uh this
the home school this law would apply to
a home school person as
uh as as their school district
operates but if a homeschooling parent
has a homeschooling schedule of friday
through
monday say a four day
homeschooling week and their off days
are tuesday wednesday and thursday this
law here
would prevent that those school children
from working tuesday wednesday or
thursday evenings
if if i may
the
that is correct but that is the current
law
and because it is way too complicated to
find out you know how many people are
homeschooling and what their schedules
might be if you if you'd like to make it
difficult for employers
you'll work that into a bill
representative army
thank you i'd like to point out i
believe that we still have laws against
leaving children alone during the day
under a certain age and that a
homeschooler would have to be figuring
out what he was going to do with those
children while he was at work
there was another c
thank you mr chairman there were a
couple of references to the current law
that i i wanted to make clear because
not everybody does understand what the
current law means
um it applies to 16 and 17 year olds so
i don't think leaving them them at home
is a legal issue
um it also does not res the current law
does not restrict homeschoolers from
working on a tuesday night
past eight past nine
past 11 if that's what
works for their situation
so the contrast is not with current law
which and i'll say it again to be clear
it does not restrict hours it restricts
over time
the contrast is with these counter
proposals that have come up
as a substitute for night work which
would
offer to restrict
either during the school year or the
current law applies only all year round
the current night work law has nothing
to do whether school's in session or not
it's
purely based on age
and it's purely a restriction on
working more than eight hours in a day
if you have worked certain hours
at least three days during the week
thank you
was it a problem
thank you mr chairman um
i'll reiterate a point which i brought
up as a question to the senator
presenting this bill at the public
hearing which was um
most of the replacements uh for the
night work session has said you can't
work past a certain time and
chairman you allude to this and
your comments as well they don't
restrict
when you can begin working
so you know if the restriction is you
can't work later than 9 pm
if a shift starts at 9 30 pm and goes
all the way through the night it would
appear to be in compliance and that just
it just doesn't make sense it doesn't
say you know
not later than 9 pm and not before dawn
or or any or not later than midnight not
before dawn it just
all these um replacements just seem to
be absent the other half of the equation
if the
to
for what they're trying to do
if
are you talking about 16 and 17 year
olds
yes that's what where this section would
apply to okay um well there are limits
to um when they can drive from what i
understand they can't drive after 11
o'clock was that that's my understanding
of the law so i think
i think what we can do obviously is make
certain assumptions that
if we make a law that takes every single
possibility
into
account
that this would be huge and it would be
more confusing than anybody could ever
deal with
i i still need to
i need to answer that businessman who
says i need a simple law to follow
and i think
aside from throwing out all of the law i
think this clarifies it and makes it
easier for people to to perform
following the law
working past night at night it's implied
that you're not going to work at 10 or
you're not going to work at two
starting hours
i don't think that matters as long as
you adhere to the 35 hours a week and no
more
so i think that answers your question
thank you yes it does but one follow-up
yes one additional comment um i think we
focused a lot on the aspect of driving
hours uh and at least my high school job
was
i'm
software development and coding
something that perfectly would have been
possible in today's age to do from home
completely with no driving and i think
all these proposals would equally apply
if it was an in-person job where you had
to report to a business
or if you were a work-from-home job as a
16 or 17 year old as well
where all the driving issues would not
be in play
any additional comments
representative smith i do like the way
you've tried to toward these things it
was some of the comments and and
um about how to alter some of these
things and some of those guys with
orange badges in the back
uh maybe you can and work on some kind
of a floor amendment because
i'm not a big fan of
no restrictions whatsoever um
as well for the points that
we all know to be true and what
representative baruti said about
individuals who um
may have different
since we're changing this parental this
needs to go back to the senate is that
right they need to approve this
if we
pass
no
so it does have to go back to
they can they can concur
they can not concur and request a
committee conference which i'd like to
see committee of conference for this
would be
preferable for from my opinion
all right any additional questions
regarding the amendment uh 202-2-1623-h
sitting uh mr clark would you please
call the roll
seaworth no
havolani
helen
no
myself no
love no
warden no
turcotte
no
pro
boyd no
murder
no
sullivan yes
susie yes broody yes cahill yes diesel
vestro
schmidt
yes toomey yes bouchard yes adjutant yes
army yes
infantine no
10 11. are there any additional
amendments to be brought forth
seeing none
a motion on the floor uh i bring it back
to representative uh seaworth for a
motion
i move out to pass as amended
second
motion has been made by representative
seaworth
second by representative turcotte
i have to let him um unless you have a
parliamentary issue i have to let him oh
that's fine yeah before uh please you're
allowed to speak to motion
thank you mr chairman i don't want to
belabor the point we've certainly
discussed um in detail the issues with
this this bill
as i said when i was talking
about some of the amendments i think
this came to us from the senate with a
clear purpose
to simplify three areas of law where
employers are feeling
tied down by the complexity
as amended i am comfortable it does just
that and
uh will be supporting the bill thank you
thank you mr chairman um i had a feeling
the amendments were going to go the way
they did today so to follow your lead i
prepared my own soliloquy
if you've gone into any of your local
restaurants shops on your main streets
or you've listened to your voicemails
you know that we have a really severe
workforce shortage in the state
when was that said
that was the prime sponsor of this bill
in senate commerce in january of 2022
introducing the bill
that sentence word for word devoid of
any further context could have been and
was said over and over and over
from march 2020 to august 2021
for the first time in my lifetime the
federal government had stepped in to
support and enhance the material
conditions of people's lives in the face
of a crisis by introducing enhanced
unemployment benefits almost immediately
forces in mainstream media swore up and
down that the 600 and then 300 benefits
were the sole thing the single thing
stopping our competitive labor market
from bouncing back and if only president
biden would stop paying people to stay
home we could once again go to our
favorite restaurants where a server in a
mask and a shield who has no sick pay
could take our orders
envy was used to pit lower income
americans against lower income americans
and it worked
in august of 2021 president biden ended
enhanced unemployment benefits and the
following jobs report was a wet plastic
bag business interest had convinced the
federal government to end the single
most impactful piece of support for
american workers since the new deal and
it flopped
turns out there was a correlation and
some may say causation that the reason
why nobody wanted to be a server who was
only guaranteed 327 an hour was because
they were a server who would only be
guaranteed 327 an hour
the reactionary method of ending
unemployment didn't fix the problem
were we then to consider a minimum wage
increase to make the low-paying jobs
more attractive to applicants what about
paid time off what about streamlining
the formation of strong labor unions to
bargain for rights or literally anything
else that has historically proven to
support the economic needs of the common
everyday person
nope of course not instead we're here
considering a bill to expand the amount
of hours that the time and the time that
children can work as a means of trying
to plug the shortage of people willing
to work for wages that nobody can
possibly live on you can tell me all you
want oh josh these aren't kids they're
16 and 17. they can't vote they can't
drink they can't smoke they can't enlist
they can't get a credit card and they
can't drop out of school in the eyes of
god in the state of new hampshire they
are children and most importantly they
are children who have homework to do
that they will not be able to accomplish
if they're working until 10 pm or beyond
10 pm now as the bill allows whenever
it sacrifices a student educational
attainment allegedly the great american
equalizer so that people don't have to
wait in line as shaw's it wait in line
at shaw's as long and i think that is
wrong
but josh this just allows kids to work
until whenever they want to it doesn't
require them to they can just ask their
manager not to schedule them
we were all here when deputy
commissioner ogden told this committee
and i quote
it's a large part of the dialogue in
these conversations you'd think you'd
say to that parent well then don't let
them work but the parents will often say
to us well if i tell my kid that they
can't work that late the employer will
just replace them with someone who can
parents see it that if they set the
barriers the kids may lose their job
well josh some families need more money
than others so their kids will have to
work nearly full time i agree that there
are poorer families than others that's
why i support bringing back the child
tax credit that's slash childhood
poverty in america that's why i support
bolstering ebt and cash assistance or
raise the minimum wage to 15 bucks an
hour
i agreed that the nightwork rule
currently in statute is confusing if we
want to clean that up and set good
restrictions i support that that can be
done while keeping a cap at 9pm so our
kids can do their homework and get to
bed
if you want younger servers to clear
cups fine i'd support that that can be
done with just set it without setting
non-existent hour caps and just punting
the remainder of the bill except for the
first section
but when those two things are ruled out
as justifications it only leaves what
every single person who testified on
this bill said well we have a labor
shortage and so we're going to abdicate
our responsibility to sweeten the
unfilled jobs and instead just let the
kids do it
i heard that no fewer than three times
during the public hearing that's what i
think the real drive behind this bill is
that's why i'll be voting against it
today and i hope that you will join me
in that so we can feed this motion and
send it to an interim study where it
belongs
would anyone else
like to speak
well i don't agree with everything you
said i respect your right to say it
and uh
i could
give a rat's butt about a labor shortage
uh
what i do care about is trying to make
something less confusing
while trying to figure out a way
that
we can
without being
the government parent
find a happy medium
for those that do need
uh
protection i guess from for their
parents and those who don't i guess
but
don't
throw in my face
that
this is being done to
get kids to work more hours a lower
paying jobs and i'm trying to help
a labor shortage i don't think that's
ingenuous
seeing no other comments
mr sullivan
i'm not not a big fan of floor
amendments um
but i think in this case uh
one is uh
appropriate
and i will uh support amending
representative schmidt's uh amendment
to make it clear
and
i would reiterate again that i think
having no limits on night work for
16 and 17 year olds is is definitely a
step too far
and so i think uh bringing a floor
amendment that is a little bit clearer
um a little bit more complete
um and that provides a reasonable limit
would be appropriate and
i will simply um forewarn you that
that's likely to happen and i'm hoping
that we can find enough votes of people
who don't want to see kids working until
midnight on school nights
i think maybe there might be enough
folks that will vote in favor of
something less than that thank you
thank you
mr clark would you please call the roll
the motion on the floor is ought to pass
as amended
seaworth yes
avaloni
yes
calum
myself yes love yes
warden
yes
haircut yes
bro yes boyd yes
murder yes
sullivan nope susie no rudy no cahill no
sylvestro
schmidt no to me no bouchard no hesitant
no mommy no 11 10
yes oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
all right
uh the next bill up
our last bill senate bill 209 relative
to electronic wage payments recognized
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman i'd like to
introduce amendment 2022-1634-h
and would like to speak to that
motions on the floor seconded by
representative
pro
you're recognized to speak
thank you mr chairman um
while i was not here at the hearing last
week i did go back and review the um the
tapes on it
um
and i had received some
emails and in-person uh
discussions on the changes that had come
out from the original sb 209
uh the one that we came to us as amended
by uh senate and there were
lots of issues with
lines of the the new paragraph large uh
paragraph added in 14 lines 14 through
21 and as i started to
read through that i i too saw that
that there were uh
more burdens being placed on the
businesses more regulations more
penalties more
everything and
the one that really caught my attention
immediately was
um
should an employee payroll payroll
employees payroll card be lost i'll
leave out the rest of it the employer
shall provide the employee with a
replacement payroll card within 25
four hours of being notified
and
immediately i thought to
again like not that i've ever done this
but on a friday night
going out and
leaving a credit card somewhere or
misplacing a
credit card or doing something
why would it be on the employer
to
open up his business on a weekend
to go in and make good with a
replacement payroll card for
the employer employee who had lost that
card again just one example
uh so
as i dug deeper and deeper into this and
i went further and further down the
rabbit hole it once again came to me the
the saying of the bureaucracy that
governs best governs least
and
i just pulled out the entire
act
rsa 275 i was just amazed at how
much we tend to try to
dig down and solve every little issue
here every little issue there and let
instead of letting the employer and the
employee
you know figure out their arrangements
having said all that i i went back and
simply
reintroduced
um this amendment is nothing more than
the original bill sb 209
uh so i would ask that you support that
thank you
representative sullivan
i guess i'd like to
paint a picture of the type of employee
that we're talking about here
this is an employee who probably does
not have a bank account or
many of the people who take these cards
will not have a bank account
they will likely be living from
day to day dollar to dollar
with no extra
spending money whatsoever
if they are getting their payroll
sent to this payroll card
the only money they may have would be
the payroll card
if they
if the card is damaged or stops working
and i know that you know my debit cards
take a beating and
often i suddenly find that i've got a
debit card that doesn't work anymore
i can at least go to the bank and do a
withdrawal
but this person doesn't have an account
all their money is tied up on that card
they've got no other money
the card is is no longer working they
have no money
they can't buy gas they can't buy food
they can't pay the rent if it's due
they have no money
they they need to be able to get their
money access to the money within 24
hours we heard testimony that employers
are given blank cards that can quickly
be um
run through a machine and uh and set up
so that that employee can again gain
access to the only place they have any
money which is on that card
um so i would point out that um
getting access quickly is going to be
important um without that 24-hour limit
the employer has no obligation to
provide a replacement card at all
unless and then perhaps that employee
would have to file a complaint with the
labor department and then wait for a
hearing to find out um how they're going
to get access to their money i think
that clause was put in there for a good
reason and it ought to stay thank you
thank you mr chairman i i think the uh
the language that was added by the
senate is similar to that where uh
where uh direct deposit or a paycheck
uh is lost or you know doesn't work and
the the employee is entitled to their
money
timely
and there can be fines for not providing
that money in a timely fashion
so i don't think we want to exempt
payroll cards from those provisions
governor seaworth
thank you mr chairman and and thank you
representative
i was trying to think of of how to say
that and you you described it very well
um the essence of this bill
is
not the addition of pay pay cards which
is already in current law
but the removal of the requirement to
pay by check
that's what this bill is doing and i i
believe the representative is correct
that if
an employee loses their check
between leaving the workplace
and
getting getting to the place where they
can cash it or there's some technical
problem where they show up with the
check and it can't be cashed
these issues do apply and these issues
are in existing law
and whether we could probably
quiz the director the deputy director if
he were here before us exactly how they
might deal with that situation
if it were a check but i i believe that
you're correct that it's not that
um
without all these details
the employer doesn't have to pay anybody
anymore i i think the existing labor law
does have a way of doing it yes the
amendment from the senate
which is the original bill that we
considered
has a lot of details specific to payroll
cards
but that doesn't mean by removing all
those specifics we exempt payroll cards
from the regulations that apply to all
the other forms of pay
that are currently allowed by law and
would continue to be allowed by law
thank you mr chairman
thank you
representative avilani
thank you mr chairman
the 24 hours is basically
um
if an employee is paid on friday they
call their employer on saturday six
o'clock hey i lost my card i can't have
access to my
funds
they can certainly issue a card within
24 hours however it's not going to be
linked to their account until monday
morning
just because you have blank payroll
cards does not mean you can go and
automatically link them to a
clearinghouse account
like adp or paychecks or something like
that you don't have that ability you can
issue a card with their name on it and
give them a number and then in turn that
number is linked to their account within
adp by their
employee id number
the 24 hours having the employer on that
hook for that 24 hours is unworkable if
it's a saturday or a sunday
with the payroll card
they can certainly issue a check but
this is saying they need to replace
that payroll account within 24 hours of
being notified
that's the rub i have
yeah i just wish peg cards would go away
um
uh i think they did
my personal opinion is they feed
people too much
uh i'm happy to see that this is new
technology coming on unfortunately
you'll have to have a smartphone but new
technology where you don't need a card
as everything's done there and you can
tap things and there's no fee and
everything else i think these pay cards
should go away
um the only thing i do like about what
we've done here is
you can still ask for a check
and i thought that was my you know
i don't want to keep talking guys but
i've two things i really believe
strongly in all my years here number one
tips are 100
owned by the employees that's what you
get taught in the labor committee that's
what stays a committee number two you
are an employee unless you can prove
otherwise and number three
should be it's your money
i earned it
make it easy for me to get it
and that's why i'm old-fashioned and
give me a check so i can go cash it
um try to use a credit union where
there's limited fees and i'd love to get
rid of these things
but that's not what's in front of us
i was in cahill
thank you mr chairman uh
i reached out to a constituent who is an
employer
and
to ask about
her practice their practices with
payroll cards may i just
read briefly her uh reply sure
thank you
oops wrong one
okay
uh good morning representative cahill
this is holly novoleski from novel iron
iron work you would appreciate that
mister yep oh seacoast
um
between my two companies i employ
approximately 130 people we give paper
checks and direct deposit we have
individuals who requested a green dot
prepaid type of card we said that we
don't do that and issued them a paper
check
oops
no further concerns from them our
experience with green dot prepaid card
is this my son works here he's president
our payroll department got an email
supposedly from him asking that his
direct deposit be moved to green dot by
the time we realized it had been several
they've done several weeks pay have been
transferred we work with our bank td but
none of the money could be recovered no
tracking we were told that the type of
that type of scam is generally from
overseas the money goes out of the
country and is not recoverable so we
refuse to use prepaid debit cards for
payroll direct deposit to an established
bank or paper check
that's good i hope this helps please
feel free to reach out for any questions
so that's something i wasn't aware of
that there's these scams out there i
worried about you know being hacked and
you know every institution is vulnerable
to hacking whereas you get the check in
your hand like you said mr chairman you
can take it to the bank
[Music]
can we take payroll cards out
you can if you'd like to make it a full
amendment floor amendment
unfortunately i think there a huge
revenue source for some of these payroll
companies which is dastardly
all right
there are no further comments the
motions on uh the the
amendment
uh the
two zero two two desk one six three four
eight would you please call the role mr
clark
seaworth
yes
yes so yes love yes
turcotte yes
pro yes boyd yes
merner yes
sullivan no
susie no broody
no
cahill no lisa vestro
schmidt
no
toomey
bouchard no
adjutant no homie no
every time yes
11 10.
the motion um
we we have a um
representative attitude had submitted an
uh an amendment which
was presented to all of you last week
um
essentially it was adding back on the
information on the bill that uh
remembers of addition and i had placed
regarding
quotas
and
but the speaker
because of
because of what happened with the first
bill we dealt with today i submitted the
uh
the amendment
and it was ruled
by the speaker to be um non-germane
and not having a time to have a
non-germane
hearing
um
that's why it will not be taken up today
but i
do you have any comments i'll be
offering you the comment
i will tell you that if i'm elected is
coming back
so
um
that being said there are no other
amendments that i'm aware of
i'm looking for a motion
uh motion to accept uh sp209 as amended
motion on the floor seconded by
open for comments
representative you're recognized i beat
your motion
sure thank you mr chairman uh sb209 as
amended is the original uh bill we've
discussed that i think at length already
so i will limit my comments to that
president of cahill and representative
yeah i'd just like to uh for the benefit
of those who weren't here um there were
no businesses who came
to speak about the need for payroll
cards
uh i think this is an issue for the
payroll card people
uh the revenue that they'll see from
this and the use of more plastic
and perhaps even the people who have
collection agencies will benefit one day
from all this but there is no need in
the business community for this
provision
so i will be voting against it
i remember the attitude followed by
sullivan
thank you mr chairman i would simply say
that i agreed with the points that you
made um
regarding uh wishing payroll cards would
go away
um and the concern
um
with folks ability to get the money that
they earned and as a consequence of that
i will be voting against the otp motion
i think um testimony indicated and i
think uh just our general knowledge
indicates that uh the vast majority of
people have moved to direct deposit and
um and that works for me it works for
most everyone um there's a few dinosaurs
out there who like checks better than
direct deposits um and this uh
i wouldn't be offended if people who
have bank accounts um
were required to go from a paper check
to a direct deposit
what
does offend me though is people who
don't have bank accounts being forced to
have their payroll
put on a card
um they should have continued to have
the option and the cards
you know can exist if somebody really
wants to do it that way
i wouldn't stand in their way
but
i would say that
people who don't have bank accounts
ought to be able to get a paper check
and an opportunity to cash it
in at a convenient location as the law
currently indicates um
it's only a few people
um they um
it i don't think it's a great deal
difficulty for an employer to issue a
few paper checks
and it'd be far better than putting
their money on a card that's going to
get hit with
a lot of fees as has been described so i
will be opposing this
i'm sorry i apologize
i just want to clarify something you
said
thank you mr chairman i
we're whispering something and that's
rude so i'll say it out loud for
everybody
um
i think
to distill this multi-page bill down to
a single sentence
um the purpose of this bill
is the removal of
the option that the employee can insist
on a paper check
regardless of what the employer wants
that leaves and and this applies both to
the version that came to us from the
senate as well as the version that we've
just amended they're both identical in
that regard they strike the sentence
that allows the employee to override the
employer
when there's an issue with how to be
paid
current law the employee can say you
know what i don't like any of your
options i want to check
um
that sentence is being removed
right
i don't like crappy legislation
i don't like i don't like the lesser of
evils
i don't like what the senate did to us
this year
i think it's rude and unprofessional
mr clerk you can call the roll
emotion on the floor is about to pass
the amendment i'm sorry representative
avilani
thank you mr chairman um
would we as a committee be able to
remove
payroll cards next session
if we just took out section d
would we be able to do that
i'm sure you'd have a number of payroll
card people coming in here crying foul
but you could try to do anything you'd
like i think it'd be nice to have them
in front of us
i think we need to do whatever we can
to make someone that worked for a pay
get their pay
is easy as possible with as few fees as
possible
and time to come up with a compromise
between what is good for the employer
and the employee but you know what it's
the employee's money
not agree more mr chairman
i'll just say if you took out deed
and if you took that out and
representative seaworth's point stands
that the underlying
um
outcome of the legislation
is that
the employee no longer has the ability
to request a check
and they don't have direct deposit
what would that leave with
i
okay
no that's why i was whispering to my
vice chairman earlier
there's not a fail
i i think the most direct path to what
we want is to just vote no on the on the
bill
and leave the law as it is today
now there's nothing there's nothing to
prevent an employer from encouraging
uh an employee you know you know here's
these here's a list of credit unions and
you could join one of those it's five
dollar minimum balance and you can have
it you can have a debit card from them
if you want to i have no responsibility
about the fees for the that they may
have with the debit card but if you go
to a credit union and avoid those
dreadful minimum balances at the regular
banks
you can have direct deposit
but i think we should not be taking away
the option of a paper check for those
who prefer it we should not make it a
bank account or a debit card a condition
of employment
motion on the floor
is on to passive amendment
mr clark could you please call the roll
seaworth
yes
abhilani
callum
yes
myself no
love
yes
borden yes
bearcat
yes
boyd yes
burner
yes
sullivan no
susie
no
rudy no
diesel estro
schmidt
no to me no bouchard no adjutant
homie no
infantine no
12 9.
yes motion of itl
motion on the floor is itl has it been
seconded
seconded by sullivan
any discussion
i'm not going to vote for itl i'm going
to
go for another motion
that's what that motion
might be we'll save some time
i'll withdraw the motion mr chairman if
i could make a motion for interim study
instead
i'm not going to make them well i can't
make the motion
oh i'm sorry
yeah
and i thought you withdrew your motion
you said i did but followed up with
promotion for studying motion floors in
terms of study in your second so
secondary sullivan
comments
you need to wait a minute here i'm sorry
that's right
there we go okay
please call the roll
uh seaworth
no
avalani
callum
yes
myself yes love
gordon no
turcotte no
wrote no
boyd no
murder
no
sullivan yes susie yes
rudy yes
d sylvester i'm sorry cahill yes di
salvestro
schmidt yes
to me
bouchard yes hesitant yes
i'll be yes
infantine
yes
14 7.
so any other business before this
committee
see none please get your uh blurbs um to
me um
by no later than monday i have to report
everything out on wednesday
mr chairman yes since we voted a couple
bills interim study
if they passed the house that way
then when are we going to meet
to discuss those sometime in the summer
if the senate concurs august september
um
right it'll be after
we usually have some time when there's
the meeting rooms are shut down
why don't you do that
right for check
angry yeah all right thank you everyone
i appreciate that you
understand that was awful
all right
oh
hey